what up guys my name is Pearl all of
them are just some of them 99 you mean
just a liberal ones then no 100 okay
do you think do you think women are
smart yes I do where's the female Elon
Musk
I think there's many of them it's just
name one
one woman's so smart as Elon Musk or
Bill Gates
yeah nobody comes to mind right now you
know what do you know nobody comes to
your mind you know it's funny who's the
rich millionaires Kim Kardashian Kylie
Jenner yeah I know are they smart no
they're not but that doesn't make it
like what was the word you said before
you said healing women are smart yeah
you can be smart and not be rich you
know you can be a politician and he gets
a lot to get there I mean
oh this is a crook all right so I have a
question I have a question do you think
women make good decisions I think
they're human so we make mistakes as
much as men but yeah usually I think
because why does everyone have a toxic
ex-boyfriend oh yeah that's [__] up
yeah
isn't that like yeah yeah but but it's
not like the most important decision we
made yeah yeah and we all decide
terrible I know yeah definitely so so
knowing this so we we're dumber and we
decide worse than men should we have an
equal vote as men oh man
I guess we do yeah yeah because there's
also [__] men
good morning at night we're in a toxic
relationship you know but yeah yeah okay
okay so women are in net taxpayer loss
meaning we spend more money than we make
okay okay so on top of that on top of
that we're easy to manipulate with
propaganda so they'll show us a video of
a 12 year old chick that can't get an
abortion and we just run to the polls
we're like oh my God I need to go vote
for this 12 year old and and then on top
of that we make up more of the
population and we don't do any of the
hard jobs so building the buildings the
roads all that we don't really do it so
knowing that should we really is it fair
that we get an equal set I think we do
because that's not even the hardest job
I don't think a man could easily do what
women do around the world and do not get
the credit for like during the week most
women kept doing their job at home and
taking care of the kids okay and most
men like wearing set up with that
responsibility because it is socially uh
it's not my first language English so I
don't know how to say it but it's not
socially implied that we do the job that
men do and then men do the job that we
do what's harder an oil rig or you risk
your life every day or raising a kid I
think raising a kid definitely really
yeah I think for me
I don't want to have kids man I would
rather go there and do that job than
having kids okay have you seen the guys
that scale these buildings I know you're
tolerated so I would do that I'd rather
do that you have to change diapers every
day man like definitely not my thing
it's up to everybody you know question
okay so you you mentioned women don't
get the credit they deserve I
so then why do we have women's
empowerment we don't have men's
empowerment if we that is already
implied it's been like that for years
why are there reaches men why are there
reaches people man because it is a
system why are there because women don't
do the work we're lazy I don't think we
are I really don't think okay then why
do we pick when we can do anything we
pick to do only fans there's more only
fans workers than teachers now oh really
yeah yeah yeah so so we could go work
and go but we just take off our clothes
no that's your choice I mean it's a free
world you want to do that I think it's
the same value as working on an oil
company well and I don't think it's easy
okay okay let me just oh come on you
think me getting naked so if I just took
off my clothes and said take some
pictures with me that would be as easy
as building that building no it's
different obviously but I do think that
both of them have difficulties no but
equal such thing as equal okay okay I
would say one but you have to pick which
one's harder I won't pick one no not for
me man I'm taking off clothes oh come on
you know if you just take out your
clothes you're not gonna make the money
that a guy is gonna do you know how much
they make there are women
there are women making a million a month
on only fans yeah and you think that's
more important than the men who are
voting these roads these structures
saying that so what are you saying I'm
not saying it's more important I say
that it has the same value same value if
it's not as important
do you think women are smart
it needs more context but sure yeah then
where's the female Elon Musk right
we're everywhere we're just not seen all
right do you think we make good
decisions not in Vegas when we're drunk
but otherwise sure then why do we all
have these toxic ex-boyfriends
because sometimes it takes that life
experience to learn from it to become a
smarter woman do we ever really learn
yeah is that what we see yeah your
friends okay your friends that data
toxic guy they think all right I'm done
and they really stop and the next guy is
really better sometimes sometimes a good
guy but like
there are few few and far between you
know so you gotta really hunt for them I
think women
women shouldn't vote yeah I think we I
think we make dummy decisions just take
it back yes yeah like we shouldn't have
bank accounts either well yeah I think
have you seen our credit cards we just
run them
you know we spend more even though we
make less well
if the men were in control of the money
I think we'd have a lot less debt no no
it's because consumerism is tailored to
me so everything I say I want
no that's true because they realize
we're idiots and we'll just buy whatever
they say yeah like this hat
so if you had to go to war
and it meant giving up your right to
vote
so okay so like you get to vote but you
have to go to war
or you don't have to go to war but you
don't vote what are you picking it's a
very cynical question because I don't
really think my vote counts anyway even
if I went to war I wouldn't be the one
going into war anyway what do you mean
the men would right the men was right so
remember we're voting for the
commander-in-chief so the guy that's
sending everyone to war so shouldn't the
guys that have to go to war vote on it
no that that commander-in-chief should
just be a woman no women
okay so in like Society like like um the
men had to go out and do the hunting
right because if they died it didn't
matter the women would carry on the
society oh no well you know what you
know what happened the last 500 years
they took all the women that were in
power we're more likely to wage more
than men we get our periods and we're
like ah no we couldn't we can handle it
and if the men got it they couldn't the
whole world would shut down well are we
not free tampons or well we'd have free
everything because women just give stuff
away like our bodies on only fans
I've bought some
money damn near might as well be you
look at the strip it's basically free on
the Strip anyway I just don't know how
we could say as a group we make good
decisions when there's more only fans
workers than teachers now if we breed
the nipple we wouldn't have to charge
five dollars well why would we see
that's a silly idea why did you see this
one let's charge five dollars to look at
Men's nipples because if it's hot and we
have to wear a shirt they should have to
too well but we're not attracted to that
you know that it's not the same because
we can control our impulses no no
because like we're just the hotties like
we look great for that and then aren't
the hotties they're not they're the
workers like they go to work and we're
like damn that's hot it's disposable I
mean some women treat them as disposable
yeah so we should be running the world
no no actually I think we live in a
matriarchy now
and I'll tell you why so
I've talked to politicians about this
they cannot get elected without women
so single women are the number one swing
voters so all of the laws are catered to
women
's like it's actually all of society is
for women right now
like we have we have women's rights
right I've never heard anyone talk about
men's rights when men have to get
custody of kids right that's like that
that are more likely to commit like men
of all these issues nobody cares but
women it's like all we ever talk about
is women's problems because we have more
of them and nobody has talked about them
for so long well if we have more
problems then why don't we commit more
because we're stronger of course really
yeah the men that built the buildings
are stronger than us they have they have
this kind of strength and we have it
everywhere else well then why don't we
have the mental strength to not do only
fans
like it's like we're so do you have an
only fan what's your adult I'll follow
you no I don't I don't but I I've met a
lot of supporting women you know and Men
supporting women well if women want
supporting men I'll tell you what I do
I'll tell you what I do I did female
sports and if women really want to just
support women they would have been in my
games but none of these feminists ever
came
what I'm saying that's why they don't
really care they'll support they'll ask
her the fans link but not not my
basketball game it's so crazy I'm sorry
I know because basketball takes a lot
more effort and time and training years
of experience yes skills yeah the only
fans that's just get naked yeah everyone
can do that that's what I'm saying what
about do you think we should be fighting
for equal men's pay in modeling and only
fans so here's a okay so if the men
wouldn't buy it then the women wouldn't
sell it right yeah so I think it's just
about what you can sell things let the
women Market or anything else if us
women chose to get married then they
wouldn't have to go to only fans but
we're not getting married so it's like
they're like well I need it somewhere
because look at our choices or oh my God
look at all their choices we're a bunch
of fat we're all fat like 70 of us are
fat we're nice on the inside no we're
not we're not we're actually more likely
to kill the infants and the elderly yeah
women are more likely to have kids Now
population control is a bad thing right
the population's out of control
someone's got to keep the numbers down
we're not sending the men out to get
eaten by tigers anymore so you agree
with population control this is what we
think we gotta control a little bit wow
or or save the bees but there you can't
have both or what save the bees what do
you mean like we're gonna run out of
food for all the people how do you know
that because I see the bees dying every
day so you saw some boy let me get this
straight the laundry
let me get this straight The Logical
women saw some bees die yeah and now
we're gonna run out of food yeah yeah
and you think we're the smarter sex and
we should run the world well I
appreciate the time chica I do I think
we agree on nothing but I like you hello
so I have a question sure do you guys
think women should vote we should preach
the gospel now to talk about whether
what but why not dang it I thought you
guys are Christians yes we are should
women vote for us because we're supposed
to submit to men's Authority huh we're
supposed this is Christian feminism it's
like we're supposed to submit to men's
Authority the natural Republic well
before it used to be landowner I know
that's what we learned we used to do a
lot of stuff yeah that wasn't right yeah
but I think it's wrong I think women
should I think you know men do all the
hard jobs in the infrastructure and
we're supposed to submit to men's
Authority oh my gosh so I thought I
thought I thought that Christians they
should do let me ask you what are you
born again that's the critical question
have you been born again yes
yeah I'm a Catholic you know what I mean
I'm a little different but so you died
tonight would you go to heaven I like to
think so okay you're not born again well
well I'm a Catholic because you're only
thinking so let me ask you this did
Jesus die for your sins yeah he did okay
he did all right he died for your sense
did he take him away
yes okay so if you were to die tonight
would you go to heaven well you just
told me he took away your sins
be see I'm I'm a Catholic so we got a
little different but we got a little
different different beliefs we don't we
don't think you can just get baptized
and go to heaven do you believe this
and Catholics do like Grace you have
been saved through faith yes yes what do
you say from hell you're sick okay yeah
so you believe that's true yes but I
think but I think hear me out hear me
out I think the only way we get all get
saved and this world stops going to [__]
as if we to repeal the 19th baby
no no hear me out this is what happened
this is what they did in the 1900s they
invented propaganda they realized that
women were dummies they could tell us
anything and we just believe it it's so
silly and so in the early 1900s they
gave women the right to vote so they
could influence off if women didn't vote
Republicans would have won for the last
hundred years all this it is pushed by
women
country yes yes this is the thing it's
the root of all evil you think women
you live in this country nobody makes
you votes well I want I want all the
women to stop and I'll stop too I can't
I can't yeah
I need I need all the women to stop with
me I gotta cancel out these checks
they're all getting them and sleeping
everywhere and it's going crazy we gotta
stop it and the only reason all this has
been passed is because they gave women
the right oh it's terrible look what do
you think this is what they do they show
us a 10 minute clip of a woman that
can't get into 12. and we run to the
polls we're like I must vote in yeah he
knows and this is the thing the natural
order of the world is God God men women
children and when we but when we say
that women should vote it's saying we're
equal we're not equal you're equal and
God judged is there an order in the home
yes and there's an order in the world I
think what do you think well what is
what is the scripture say it doesn't say
anything about women voting or not well
it says submit to your husband's
authorities right okay so so why
wouldn't we model that in the in society
why would it when men do all the hard
jobs men pay the majority of the tax
it's not quite like
I thought the Christians would be on my
side with this what I'm saying is
biblical what I'm saying is biblically
I think that you don't think we should
have a society it's biblical you know in
the house the husband's ahead well I you
know you don't think we should model
Society the same way or you think it
should be a model do you think we should
be a society that pushes families or
individuals families okay so why
wouldn't we trust our husband to vote
because when every person votes that's
anti-family because you're not trusting
your husband but it still boils down to
you have the right to vote or not to
vote
are you are you saying we shouldn't live
in a constitutionally public I'm saying
you know
that's it that's all I'm saying you
would hope that they don't yeah no I
think all women we should take those
away we gotta we gotta repeal it take it
away all these are legal now all these
taxes I think I have a tough job
preaching the gospel
what I'm saying is biblical
girl
repeal that you get anybody to agree
with you hell yeah hell yeah I got I got
a billion views on YouTube I got I got
billions of views there's so many people
that agree and you agree too I can tell
you know what I'm saying is right all
these looking I could tell and the very
conservative and I believe in a
constitutional republic if they want to
repeal it and they can do it then then
I'm fine with it yeah because I believe
in I believe in this country and I
believe what it stands for you have the
right to try to do what you're doing
it'll never happen
well you know if they just
if they just if they just as well like
okay hear me out I'm basically preaching
the gospel because the policies I'm
pushing for they do they do it's pushing
for a natural order of the world are you
talking about a theocracy go back to a
theocracy well I I don't know I don't
know
I just I just want the women
no sin
it made sin for us that we might become
the children of God
do you guys think that women are smart
at times at times absolutely okay then
where's the female Elon Musk find her
for me yet to be found
okay why do we why does why does one out
of 25 of us under the age of 35 do only
fans if we're so smart
to be a mystery because dudes will pay
[__] all right should women
of course
so I wanna I wanna pitch you guys why I
think we shouldn't vote so do you think
it's fair to do all of the work
or do you think it's fair to do none of
the work and have an equal say depends
on what like if you're so like if you
you have a house right and you pay for
the whole house you build the house
yourself doesn't make sense for someone
to move in and have more of a say if
they don't pay for anything it's not
more of a say but you're when she moves
in you're one you made that decision as
a man you think she should have an equal
sign I'm saying a roommate not a
marriage oh not a marriage no like a
roommate well I'm gonna just kick the
roommate out no matter what
it wouldn't make sense right you
wouldn't let someone live in your house
that you pay for that you built that
doesn't contribute anything no no so
we're a net tax paying loss women
meaning we spend more than we make we
don't do any of the infrastructure jobs
none of the infrastructure jobs so I
think like if we're not going to do the
same amount of work why should we get
the equal size Friends with Benefits
no but you wouldn't you wouldn't play
with friends with benefits on the deed
of your house right no people don't work
people have done a lot worse people have
but you it wouldn't be fair right yeah
to each they own okay well thank you
guys do you think women are smart
absolutely then where's the female Elon
Musk
where's the female Elon Musk she's
somewhere she's coming do you think
women make good decisions absolutely
then why do we all have a toxic
ex-boyfriend good question
good question
thanks do you think women should vote
absolutely why one more when we make
stupid decisions you don't make stupid
decisions we mix men make stupid
decisions okay okay so well guess what 1
in 25 women under 35 are on only fans
that's more women that are on only fans
than our teachers do you really think we
make good decisions sir whoa whoa you
walk walk down the strip do the women
are they dressed like they make think
about this okay all we had to do was
stay a virgin until 22. we could all
marry and stay in shape we could all
marry Millionaires and we choose to be
worse look around look around look
around look oh you know the half naked
women on this trip stop playing stop
stop playing stop playing you think
that's a good decision all right yes
really I mean the average woman makes
like 500 a month on only fans and the
top earners are managed by men
does that surprise you it does not
surprise me why doesn't it surprise you
is it because we're not that smart not
that smart
all right so women
women are a tax loss we spend more money
than we make men do the majority of the
infrastructure jobs so they build the
buildings they pay the taxes they they
pave the roads why should women have an
equal say when we don't do equal work
but you do do equal work how you
contribute you're part of the society
you're part of the environment you're
part of society so like what do we do
that contributes if we don't pay taxes
or do any of the hard times but you do
no I'm saying so we we we're the
majority on benefits and we spend most
of the money so we we do we don't do we
don't contribute money-wise so how do we
contribute being beautiful
so 70 of us are fat now you are yeah
yeah 70 of women are fat we're not even
beautiful anymore we're fatties I would
agree to that yeah so so now we don't
contribute Beauty because we're out of
shape so now what do we contribute good
questions yeah a good volleyball player
volleyball yeah I was just saying make
good softball volleyball players yeah so
so volleyball operates at a loss college
volleyball that means
softball no all women's sports operate
at a loss unless we take our clothes off
I got nothing
yeah so do women really contribute
anything to society right now they do
what children so women act okay okay so
women right now uh 50
people will never have kids they're
predicting and we're not having enough
kids to replace the population so you
need about three children per woman to
to replace the population so a hundred
years ago each woman had five kids so
we're actually not really having kids
anymore that's his fault
yeah so so like what are women
contributing now what are women
contributing
[Music]
so on top of that what they realized is
that they could show women a sad story
and we were just so silly we run to the
polls we're like oh no that 12 year old
chick can't get into let me go vote let
me go vote for the Democrats the last
hundred years we would have been a kid
every election would have been
conservative if women didn't vote
does everyone deserve a voice sure what
if what if they what if they're what if
they don't contribute everything
so in your house in your household if if
you have a homeless person that just
sits there and does nothing is that fair
that you have to that they get an equal
say on what happens in the house if they
do nothing for it
yeah
I got you got me I mean I'm kind of
making points right you're right you're
making points so maybe we shouldn't vote
I still think I'm trying I'm trying to
find something I'm trying to find it so
keep thinking let me know very nice to
meet you